let's go to the beginning a lot of
people critics quickly saying when you
said a little rocket man or fire and
fury or you know when he said oh I've
got a red button on my desk he said well
mine's bigger and it works better than
yours
how did we how did it evolve from that
to this because he did say at the very
beginning we're going to basically start
over and what that has been building
behind the scenes well I think without
the rhetoric we wouldn't have been here
I really believe that you know we did
sanctions and all of the things that you
would do but I think without the
rhetoric you know other administration's
I don't want to get specific on that but
they had a policy of silence if they
said something very bad and very
threatening and horrible just don't
answer that's not the answer that's not
what you have to do so I think the
rhetoric I hated to do it sometimes I
felt foolish doing it but we had no
choice so strategically you were doing
it well yeah I mean but I and I think he
gained respect you know he's a strong
guy Hey people were saying what's he
like he's got a very good personality
he's funny and he's very very smart he's
a great negotiator and he's a very
strategic kind of a guy one of the
problems that I think surprised
everybody I think every American should
be very happy about this is the Korean
War which has gone on for so long more
importantly there are still American
remains there and they will be
repatriated it remains it coming back
yeah and we got that at the end in fact
we have some things that you don't even
have in the report we would have to tell
us what we signed yeah missile sites
that they used for the launching of
missiles and missile research areas
that's going to be gone we made a lot of
progress tremendous amount of progress
and one of the things that I'm very
happy about we're not going to play the
war games anymore which you know how
expensive that is well
it's Meza bombers in for practice from
Guam I said how far is Guam six and a
half hours sir said that's a long way
for a big bomber times you know 20 yeah
and lots of other planes coming in so
we're not going to be doing the war
games as long as we're negotiating in
good faith so that's good for a number
of reasons in addition to which we save
a tremendous amount of money you know
those things because I hate to sound
like a pure businessman but I kept
saying what's this costing I would look
at them were coming in from the sea and
bombs exploding everything I said what
is this cost I don't even want to tell
you but it's a lot so we're not going to
be doing that as long as we're
negotiating in good faith which I think
we will be you manage the expectations I
think pretty well you didn't think
coming in here you were going to sign an
agreement and you said maybe it takes
two three four or five meetings but you
were open to going as fast or as slow as
he wanted we get along better than I
would have assumed the right from the
beginning we got a lot more done today
than I ever thought possible and he's
going back he's now headed back and he I
think he's going back to get this done
he wants to get it done you know you
hear the whole thing about his father
and other administration's or his
grandfather the fact is that he and he
brings that up but they weren't dealing
with me they were dealing with different
people would've never said nobody's ever
come close he talked about the
difference between past administrations
and yours yes but I can't say that
because I don't want to be the one
saying it at some point I'm sure he'll
say it yeah but they never got it done
and they were never disclosed either I
mean it was never to a point where they
were like we are is it is there a
history lesson to learn here and I I
think in one sense we could talk about
past administrations Reagan evil empire
mr. Gorbachev tear down this wall his
own advisers didn't want it to take
those words out of that speech and you
compare Bill Clinton gave Kim jong-un's
father three billion dollars in energy
subsidies Bendis amount of money the
mullahs in Iran you have said the worst
deal in the history of mankind that's
I've ever seen worse than NAFTA and I
think Nath is pretty bad worse than the
WTO the World Trade Organization which
frankly built China in addition to the
money that we gave them all the time you
know I mean these were terrible deals
but I would say that the Iran deal was
one of the worst I've ever seen I will
say speaking of the arraign deal since
we got out of that deal and we could do
it very easily because they never had it
approved by Congress it was just
precious must be approved by Congress I
wanted to be approved by Congress
because otherwise it's really doesn't
mean very much I wanted I I would think
anybody would want to approve by
Congress but since we took out of that
deal so we got out of that deal I think
Iran is a much different place I don't
think they're looking so much to the
Mediterranean and Syria and Yemen
they're starting to pull people out of
Yemen they're starting to pull people
out of Syria they've you know it's a
whole different thing now I did it for
nuclear but one of the side benefits is
you take a look a serious look and Iran
is not the country that it was three or
four months ago when they were much more
emboldened will certainly sanctions
played a big part the strike forces that
you sent into the region of the code and
I think at a certain point honestly I
know the Iranian people I know many of
people from around these are great
people
I really believe at some point they're
going to come back and want to negotiate
a deal